we decided to add more showcase contents
that dlc for a long time our showcases
were very broad we've never really done
things were really focused now that
we're doing more focused stories we
decided that this was a perfect time to
start doing DLC as well as focused on
characters and situations and moments in
time that fans really would enjoy and
loved to play so we decided to use
Christian in our storylines this year
because the man's been around forever
he's been in w/e since 1998 he's had his
ups and downs with tag teams and
championships he's never been able to
grasp that one thing that's the World
Heavyweight Championship if you're a
core wrestling fan you appreciate
everything he's been through over all
the years and then when you actually
feel and live through the pain and the
suffering and the almost being there in
so many different levels it means that
much more
every superstar wants to climb at the
top of that mountain Christian's one of
the greatest performers to ever set foot
in the ring seem like Christian got
close at times and that was never his
grasp and getting closer getting closer
and then taking her away he finally got
his opportunity and he finally clutched
it and got a hold of it and
instantaneously the next day he lost it
and it's about his story of trying to
get it back and ultimately having a
giant robot in his way and in Randy
Orton the matches were awesome
Randy Orton I just had unreal chemistry
in the ring for as much as we didn't
like each other we brought that brought
out the best each other there were some
of the most memorable matches of my
career and everything we did seemingly
turned to gold and I'm really proud of
that time in my career when who's or job
as proud of every single one of those
matches
Christian's story is very relatable he
produced excellent matches for years and
years and then finally got this
opportunity to be the guy was great to
see Christian finally can reach the
pinnacle of this industry because he
truly deserved it and this is the fans
chance to kind of relive that
you